so let's Linger on the social media
thing so
if you you said if you ran Facebook for
a day let's let's let's extend that if
you were to build a new Social Network
today
how would you fix
Twitter how would you fix social media
if you want to answer a different
question is if you were Elon Musk
somebody you know and you were taking
over Twitter what would you fix I've
thought about this a little bit
um
first of all let me give you a backdrop
I wouldn't actually build a social media
company at all
and the answer is the reasoning is the
following
um I really tend to believe as you've
probably gotten a sense of sort of
patterns and probabilities
and if you said to meth
probabilistically answer where where are
we going in apps and social experiences
what I would say is Lex
we spent the first decade building
platforms and getting them to scale
and if you want to think about it again
back to sort of this poker analogy
others mistakes minus your mistakes is
the value
well the value that was captured was
trillions of dollars essentially to
Apple and to Google
and they did that by basically
um attracting billions of monthly active
users to their platform
then this next wave were the apps
Facebook qq10 Tick Tock Twitter Snapchat
that whole panoply of apps
and interestingly they were in many ways
an atomized version of the platforms
right they sat on top of them they were
an ecosystem participant
but the value they created was the same
trillions of dollars of Enterprise Value
billions of monthly active users
well there's an interesting phenomenon
that's kind of hiding in plain sight
which is that the next most obvious
Atomic unit
are content creators now let me give you
two examples Lex Friedman this random
crazy guy uh Mr Beast you know Jimmy
Donaldson just the two of you alone
added add it up okay and you guys are
going to approach in the next five years
a billion people the only thing that you
guys haven't figured out yet is how to
capture trillions of dollars of value
now maybe you don't want to and maybe
that's not your State admission right
right but let's just look at Mr Beast
alone because he is trying to do exactly
that probably yeah and I think Jimmy is
going to build an enormous business but
if you take Jimmy and all of the other
content creators right
you guys are atomizing
what the apps have done
you're providing your own curated news
feeds you're providing your own curated
communities you're allowed you let
people move in and out of these things
in a very lightweight way and value is
accruing to you so the honest answer to
your question is I would focus on the
content creator side of things because I
believe that's where the puck is going
that's a much more important shift in
how we all consume information content
and are entertained it's through Brands
like you individual people that we can
humanize and understand are the filter
but aren't you just
arguing against the point you made
earlier which is what you would
recommend is the invest in the AGI the
the depersonalization because because
they they could still be a participant
in that in that end state if that
happens you have the option value of
being an enabler of that
right you can help improve what they do
again you can be this bare metal service
provider where you can be a tax
yeah right you can participate in every
thing that you do every question that's
asked every comment that's curated if
you could have more intelligence as you
provide a service to your fans and your
audience you would probably pay a small
percentage of that Revenue I suspect all
content creators would and so it's that
stack of services that is like a smart
human being it's like you know how do
you help produce this information you
would pay a producer for that I mean
maybe you would but so back to your
question so what would I do
I think that you have to move into that
world
pretty aggressively
um
I think that right now you first have to
solve what is broken inside of these
social networks
and I don't think it's a technical
problem
so just to put it out there I don't
think it's um
you know it's one where there are these
nefarious organizations that happens
brigading XYZ that happens
but the real problem is a psychological
one that we're dealing with which is
people
through a whole set of situations
have lost
belief in themselves
and I think that that
comes up as this very virulent form of
rejection that they tried to put into
these social networks so if you look
inside of comments on anything like you
could have a con like you could have a
person that says on Twitter
I saved this dog from a fiery building
and there would be negative commenters
and you're like well again
put yourself in their shoes what do you
how do I steal man their case I do this
all the time you know I get people throw
shade at me I'm like okay let me steal
man their point of view
and the best that I can come up with is
you know I'm working really hard over
here I'm trying I played by all the
rules that were told to me
I've played well I've played fairly and
I am not being rewarded in a system of
value that you recognize
and that is making me mad
and now I need to cope and I need to
vent
so back in the day my dad used to drink
he would make me go get things to hit me
with
today you go to Twitter you spot off you
try to deal with the latent anger that
you feel so a social network has to be
designed in my opinion
to solve that psychological Corner case
because it is what makes a network
unusable
to get real density you have to find a
way of moving away from that toxicity
because it ruins a product experience
you could have the best pixels in the
world
but if people are virulently spitting
into their keyboards
other people are just going to say you
know what I'm done with this it doesn't
make me feel good
so the social network has to have a
social cost you can do it in a couple
ways one is where you have real world
identity so then there's a cost to being
virulent
and there's a cost to being caustic
a second way is to actually just overlay
an economic framework so that there's a
more pertinent economic value that you
assign to basically spouting off
and the more you want to spend the more
you can say
and I think both have a lot of value I
don't know what the right answer is I
tend to like the latter
I think real world identity shuts down a
lot of debate because there's still too
much
um you know there's a sensation that
there that there'll be some retribution
um so I think there's more free speech
over here but it cannot be Costless
because in that there's a level of
toxicity that just makes these products
unusable what about a third option and
by the way all of these can work
together
if we look at this what you call the
Corner case was just hilarious what I
would call The Human Condition uh
which is uh you know that anger
is rooted with the the challenges of
life
and
what about having a um
an algorithm that shows you what you see
that's personalized to you and helps you
maximize your personal growth in the
long term such that you're challenging
yourself you're improving you're
learning there's just enough of
criticism
to uh keep you on your toes but just
enough of like the dopamine rush to keep
you entertained and finding that balance
for each individual person you just
described an AGI of a very empathetic
well-rounded friend yes exactly and and
then you can throw that person even
Anonymous into a pool of Discord and
they would be better I think you're
absolutely right that's a very very very
elegant way of stating it you're
absolutely but like you said the AGI
might be a few years away so that's a
huge investment like my concern my gut
feeling is this age thing we're calling
AGI
is actually not that difficult to build
technically but it requires a certain
culture and it requires a certain
certain risks to be taken I think you
could reductively boil down the human
intellect into
cognition and emotion
and you know depending on who you are
and depending on the moment they're
weighted very differently obviously
um cognition is so easily done by
computers
that we should assume that that's a
solved problem
so our differentiation is the reasoning
part it's the emotional overlay it's
that it's the empathy it's the ability
to steal man the opposite person's case
and and feel why that person
you know you can forgive them without
excusing what they did as an example
um
that is a very difficult thing I think
to capture in software but
I think it's a matter of when not if